can we talk about the whole um beta
tization through a thousand conceptions
process that you went through with your
marriage because i mean you like you've
been pretty open about i mean you called
yourself a big fat beta and
um you know you loved your wife to death
you didn't do do anything outside of the
marriage and it just kind of it you know
the notch sort of untied itself over
time
and you mentioned that that was because
of
i mean i don't want to put words in
wrath but but it sounds like it's
because you kind of relax in the
marriage right like did you go through
betization through a thousand
concessions yes it was i was i'm still
in love with my wife i'm very happily
married
and i was i was building a feather nest
if you know what i mean
and then one day exactly as you guys
said she says about four years ago says
i'm out of here
and it's not it's not not cheating her
that counted it's i stopped chasing
excellence
she never did
so what i'm saying to you rich is what
you guys talk about so i
i was pushing you know double xl polo
shirts and 40 inch waist
and i'm a marine you don't do that
and so today i'm down to a 32 inch waist
and a 40 inch chest i'm in the stacks
like you say five days a week now and
i'm making more money i'm working harder
i'm i'm focusing on this here
is what can i do
that makes me more excellent and when i
do
the rest falls in place
a lot of people oh yeah i'm excited i'm
glad you know i'm gonna go on a diet i'm
gonna go work out you know
or anything and the reason is
emotionally it gets in the way
and i get up this morning i go i don't
want to go to the gym
i don't want to you know we had dr
nicole on with me
who was detoxing me that detox is a
killer because all my addictions come up
you know my like like drinking and
eating
but unless she was there unless i was
going to do it you know go through the
21 day process of her
detoxifying my organs
i'd still be a fat beta male but what
came up immediately is headaches pain
misery
i hated it i wanted to eat i wanted to
drink and all this
and not go to the gym
so every time i'm in the gym i i hear
your words
you know chase excellence
what do you have to say to
the guys out there that um
i mean i i generally call them just
doomers now like they're all doom and
gloom and they would say something like
well if a guy like robert kiyosaki
couldn't keep his wife around what makes
me think i can do it like why should i
get married why should i even bother
with women
well that's that's a very very good
question you know i i don't have it as a
personal question
but
i'm still partners with my wife
businesswise
you know we're still
you know that noises from but anyway
uh
i it's like the marine corps you know
i'm glad i went through it
and i'm glad i'm married and and today
as i said the more i chase excellent the
more women i have
now what you guys call ltr that's
another question
because i'm still happily married in
many ways always not together we're
still business partners she's still my
best friend
and that's priceless you find just like
my business partners some of them have
been with me 30 years that's priceless
and i've met you know scumbag business
talk to me about about the
about the scumbags out there i mean like
there's a lot of horrible people out
there that will dupe you that will take
advantage of you do you and i mean as an
older guy like as you get older you
start to get better and better at at
like sussing them out you know
separating the wheat from the chaffs
sort of speak
how do you how do you go about sizing
somebody out you know to make sure that
they're the real deal
do you have a test or anything
that's a very very good question because
um
the rule of thumb my rich dad taught me
was that from out of every bad deal and
every bad partnership
comes a good partner
so sometimes you make it's like you date
she may be the best looking person on
earth but she's not a good person but it
makes you clear on what you want
if you know what i mean so i've had so
many horrible partners it cost me 30
million dollars to get really my last
one
because there are scumbags now this is
where my wife stepped up and where i
didn't rich
she cleaned them out
i didn't i mean i make so much money
outside my business
i didn't really care how much they stole
but my wife did and kim and she's you
know she's a beautiful blonde
she's
she's thin but she's not weak
and she went in and fired them all
and i called it it was her crossing the
rubicon
she was no longer just a pretty woman
who was smart and all this stuff
she cleaned house
and that's and that's when she cleaned
house with me too
well
sometimes when it rains it pours right
they just keep
[Laughter]
you